all right well your boy just got 99
magic definitely didn't mean to do that
I forgot I was one cast of anything away
from 99 and what go ahead and start
testing this and of course but yeah I
guess that's cool I meant to get it on
both my accounts at the same time over
here on large XP lamp I am 98 one mill
away from 99 but you know it is what it
is alright hello everyone how you guys
doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day today we're here with
another video and today's video is going
to be a really sick money making method
that has been around for a while now
however recently due to an update it has
gotten drastically better and that is
the spin flax spell so if you guys are
not aware basically what this spell does
you need to have the lunar spell book
unlocked to be able to use it along with
76 magic now with that said each spell
you end up using two nature's and one a
stroll along with five heirs now you can
use an air staff that way you don't have
to actually use any heirs of course
Daddy
and basically what each of these spells
does is the two nature's and the one
Astro will make five of your flax into
five bow strings now typically this
wasn't that good of money both strings
used to be you know around 120 GP per
one but because of the new update with
make all bow strings have been very
volatile in price because for the most
part people don't actually want to put
bow strings on the bows because with a
make all update obviously people want to
afk as much they can they've just been
making unstrung bows and bow strings
have literally blown up in price so as
you guys can see I'm gonna go ahead and
buy one now that yeah the med price
right now is 156 bow strings I actually
buy for 200 that's like that's almost
double what they used to be granted okay
insta sell for 190 even then still
insane profit so advert out to 195
you're still making a ton of GP per one
so as you guys can see I bought flex for
3 GP per one and overall you end up
using two nature's and one astral as I
said before now so to nature one astral
and five flex how much you input on each
spell and obviously output you get 1000
GP / five bow strings so you're making
400 GP per cast and it's not that hard
to do I'm gonna go ahead and go to a
bank and show you guys really how to do
it and how you guys can make a ton of
money now this is a really good method
because you get close to 85 K magic XP
and 85 K crafting XP per hour and you'll
also be profiting now typically I would
say that this probably isn't worth it as
a method but since the GP per hour has
gone up a ton and
actually pretty viable it's now worth it
more than ever and I don't see that this
could really slow down now obviously
they Lou the price of bow strings could
even go down to 160 170 back to where
they are now but even with that said
with the new mobile update coming out
people aren't going to be putting bow
strings and unstrung bows together as
much so the prices may even be better
than one thing I will say as far as how
you're gonna want to set up your bank in
inventory basically you're going to want
no nature runes or in your bank
and you're gonna want to go ahead and
fill now once you have it full there is
one thing that you're going to need and
that's going to be another item in your
inventory the reason why that you're
going to need another item it can
literally be anything is because each
one of these spells does 5 flex now even
if you only have one flex right here
this would be obviously just the 26th so
that would be one flesh you'd still be
able to cast it but you'd only be doing
it on one flex and you'd be losing money
so just to show you guys what an average
inventory looks like just go ahead and
have your bank's set up like so flax
down here in the bottom right to make it
nice and easy now just press escape and
then whatever key is your magic and then
just cast it 5 times now obviously 150
XP drops per one definitely really nice
as I said before you can average 85k
magic and crafting per hour now this is
a little clique intensive is you can
only do 5 cast before you actually have
to go to the bank but even then all you
do you just do that click out and then
you can keep going now obviously if you
have better clicks than I do you can do
that a little bit quicker and you can
even get higher than 85 K but even now
it's still a really good method I'm
gonna go ahead and test this out and see
what I can get as far as hourly rates
for you guys and hopefully it is a ton
of GP I'm thinking around 600 K but it
could be more so after some testing I
found the eighty-five case does seem to
be the rate of XP that you can get for
mage and crafting per hour now obviously
this means that per hour you're gaining
170,000 XP total and that is definitely
really good as far as a mage method
alone this compared to something like
high alkane granted I know not a lot of
people high out as much but high alkane
78 K XP per hour so on top of that
you're getting another 7k or 8k and
you're getting 85 K crafting XP and 600
K well I guess that's kind of the big
part of this is the fact that if you're
doing 85 thousand XP per hour and it
comes at 75 per cast that means on
average you should be doing about 1.1
5000 casts per hour and if
you're profiting 400 GP per one that
means you'll be profiting somewhere
around 500k per hour now this is
definitely really good as far as the
money making method you know 500k per
hour is always I guess decent depending
on what you're doing the way I see this
is if you combine a decent money making
method at 500k per hour high lking at 78
K per hour which is even that great this
is better than high alkie and on top of
that molten glass is a pretty afk method
that people do for crafting and this
gets you more XP per hour than molten
glass depending on what you're doing so
this is definitely a really good method
all around and I would more than
recommend doing it right now considering
the margins are really good and this is
probably one of the more efficient ways
to go about training your account if
you're not like some high HP person
that's doing magic can be you for all of
your magic XP so hopefully you guys
enjoyed the video if you guys it makes
you leave a like I was trying to get
this out as soon as I could for you guys
because the margins are insane right now
and I want you guys to go ahead and be
able to take advantage of that so
hopefully you guys get as much as you
want out of this it's definitely a
really good method all around and I'm
more than happy with sharing it with you
guys so if you guys enjoy the video make
sure to leave a like if there's anything
you want to tell me comment down below
if you guys want to see my content and
soon as it comes out in the future it
make sure to subscribe but with that
said hopefully get some wonderful day
and peace